NINE GAMES IN THEIR
NEXT 19.
LINE.
MILLER IN
TO HUGHES.
AN EXCELLENT MOTHE A
MAN.
YOU HAVE GOT TO
ELIMINATE THGHT.
BLIDH ON A SOLO RUSH. E
TAKE THE ICE IN FRONT
OF HIM AND A TAXI TO
McAVOY GOES
FORWARD.
TO GRZELCYK.
JANE THE LINE OFF OF
THE STICK FROM SMITH.
BOUNCES DOWN INTO THE S
MILLER TO FEED
BIT OF CONFIDENCE.
YOU FEEL GOOD ABOUT
YOUR PERFORMANCE, YOU
SOME RISK HERE.
YOU WANT TO BE
AWFULLY SURE WHETHER
IS THAT DALE ARNOLD
ROSTER GOING TO LOOK
LIKE LATER IN THE
YEAR.
IT IS COMFORTING TO
KNOW THAT THAT IS HOW
BRAD MARCHAND FEELS.  B
YOU CAN SEE HE JUST
>> EMPHATIC IN HIS
DISALLOWING AT WINS THE
THAT IS JUST A SHOT
AND A
HIM.
TUMBLES IT INTO THE
ONE.  IN!
AROUND THE PAINT.
AND SHOT
MUFFLED.
THE STICKHANDLING
MOVE.
BUT IS GOING TO HAVE
A STRONG STICK.
HE'S GOT TO FINISH
THE PLAY.
HE IS ABLE TO DO IT,
MARCHAND.
BERGERONONHAD HIS HE E
ON-SITEING TO HAVE 12
SECONDS TO